good evening I am Stuart brand from the
long now foundation it seems like people
are having longer productive lives and
longer productive collaborations and
they use Joe's just noticing that for
whole if there was for long now there's
whole earth and whole earth goes back to
1968 and as early as 1976 there was an
issue of a coevolution quarterly which
is sort of a supplement the Whole Earth
Catalog but then Peter Warsaw was so
much in the thick of that whole process
that we had a guest attitude issue on
watersheds I was just reminiscing about
this this is 41 years ago I was just
reminiscing with Peter about it and one
of the things he did was a watershed
quiz he calls various people and asking
where the water came from and where I
went to and they flushed it and what the
name of the watershed therein was like
and so Wendell Berry and Lynn Margulis
and rusty Schweickart and Gregory
Bateson and so on Paul Krassner had
interesting answers editor of the
realist Peter asked him when you turn on
the faucet where does your water come
from and he said from my naive sense of
trust or salsa well that's a fine action
answer actually when you flush the
toilet where does it go and Kraft said I
never flush my toilet appears well do
you know where and what you're a
drainage basin or your watershed might
be called and Krassner said downhill
that's what we're Saul does he provokes
us into realizing our connection with
time culture nature science every aspect
of biology water all these connective
things and tonight we see how light is
another connective your horse all hope
this works because I got hugged so many
times I think I got my sound system
wrong
I want to first of all thank Stuart who
of course gave me the opportunity to
work on holders catalog and a lot of
other opportunities throughout really my
whole life so after I came to California
and Ryan who whose enthusiasm got me
here tonight last night this whole
PowerPoint collapsed and there was
nothing and then Danielle and Austin
helped me put it together as Kevin Kelly
used to say when I was at hold earth
I had one of the most nonlinear minds he
had ever met and so now you're gonna see
the combination of a nonlinear mind with
a bricolage of various slides so please
bear with me I'd like to dedicate this
to author Oh Kimura who is a Bay Area
artist of great talent and elegance who
really when I first came to California
and had no money hired me as his
assistant at the California College of
Arts & Crafts to go around with him and
show his students what it was like to
look at the same flower if you were a
maniacal naturalist like me or an artist
like he was
and so author is passed on but this
picture is really typical of one of his
great talents which is to see the bright
light that goes through the fog or the
clouds on a gray beach out in Bolinas he
also did this beautiful painting the
same thing he just had a wonderful eye
for what I call local luminance locales
yeah the other person I'd like to
dedicate this to who just passed on on
these are two pictures of single cells
that went as far as you could go to try
to be like an octopus or a human eye
they have a cornea they have a retina
they have the ability to move the
eyeball around which is it's almost its
complete body and these two you know
cells were sent to me by Lynn Margulis
and she said your talk on coloring light
is just only 500 million years old you
have to really start getting realistic
Peter life's been around for 3.8 billion
years and so what was supposed to be a
one-year book has now turned into a
two-decade book because I had to fill in
the gaps for 3.85 billion years to 500
million years and so lynn also just
passed on four whole earth and for us
she was this brilliant kind of
imaginative person that I knew since
1963 and so I want to dedicate that to
both author and Lynn my job tonight is
kind of The Naturalist task and I've
never really defined it but I thought
that you should know that a naturalist
is someone who tries to empty their mind
of a human centered universe of human
centered thoughts of human centered
agendas and in
sted tries to work towards a gyein way
of thinking about the world in this case
a guy anesthetic at the same time that
you're doing this euro of course aware
that you're human and you can never
really easily escape the human world
view as you're doing it so it's kind of
a tension that you create as you walk in
the savanna or in the Sinaloan thorn
scope about how to look at the world not
from your point of view but from the
point of view of any creature you're
walking by what the other thing a
naturalist does is to try to think of
images as color patterns in a slice of
time in other words we don't know
exactly what color others are absorbing
and receiving and if they come in blobs
or patches but you start the naturalist
considers all species in space-time as
equally beautiful and after looking at
that species for a while and some people
like myself fell in love with birds and
then Jaguars and then a town squirrel
but you while you're looking at them and
considering you're beautiful if you
don't think they're beautiful
then you think of how you colonized your
mind with a certain critics adjudication
to say that this thing is somehow not as
beautiful as it looks
so
as this the Sun pours forth photons they
take about eight minutes to get to the
earth before they meet Jane Mansfield
and Sophia Loren and photons themselves
have no material substance and you can
only know about them when they entangle
with matter or flesh they are
nevertheless envision both is waves and
as particles or wavicles by prymatt
chromatic applied scientists and their
ultimately mysterious to those who have
and dwell in a poetic imagination Fiat
painters or poets and so there's always
been this kind of metaphysical
connection between art and science that
very few people talk about and that's
the when you say the energy of a
painting what do you actually mean by
the word energy but if you ask what is
light you get into the same confusion as
a scientist this was noted by the way by
a Tang Dynasty art critic named heal
soul who called that energy Chi and so
what we're seeing right now is through
our ignorance of what energy is that
Western thoughts and Eastern philosophy
are actually coming together I'll get
you off this back to the Sun huh this is
important because you'll hear in this
talk the difference between the
pragmatic and the poetic and those two
organizations of thought between the
pragmatic and poetic are really what is
the dialogue that's going on about light
color and life on the pragmatic side the
concern is how do you accept separate
the signal from the noise how do you get
the object isolated from the background
and how do you look at the anatomy of
the eye and its importance in doing that
in the poetic end of it you're
organizing your thought by knowing that
light is knowledge at a distance there's
a separation it's not touch and at that
distance what happens is after a billion
years or so that distance and from the
light becomes part of the body either in
a circadian rhythm connected to the Sun
or moon but also in an anticipation of
what can happen because you've been
expecting all this going to the light or
going to the dark if you're a euglena
for instance and the expectation the
anticipation of what where the light is
becomes an expectation which becomes a
kind of yearning and we don't know at
what point in the history of the earth
into expectation became yearning and
yearning then became what is the basis
let's say if you're a roomie of human
life which is desire and so what we see
when we see all this that desire then in
as it gets very elaborated but maybe an
octopus we don't know but gets into hope
and transcendence and so images are
these things that excite the inner self
to do something in the world of how to
be in the world that go from
anticipation expectation yearning desire
hope and transcendence know here's a the
pictures will get prettier and more like
micro cosmos as we go on the reason
they're here so here are the four stages
of aesthetics you have to consider what
your energy source is for light you have
to consider how it's been modified by
the biosphere you have to consider how
it interacts with matter the aesthetic
surface and how its received by the frog
or Sophia Loren to have a receptive
creative life
one thing that's really clear about the
pragmatics and the poetic is that
they're inseparable because when you are
trying to figure out what the object is
from the background all that background
is still going into you is still
becoming part of the inner self and
that's what certain scientists who are
adventurous we call the bodily
unconscious and that bodily unconscious
only emerges once again in the way that
we don't yet understand to become what
we call the creative so I want to really
emphasize that what comes in the
receptive is equal to the creative and
people have not emphasized what goes in
and how it how the receptive becomes the
creative and it is impossible not to
have these extras in the visual system
let me say that those are what Wallace
Stevens calls the restatements of poetic
organization the son becomes the trick
gets restated by biospheric light as it
goes through the clouds and the ozone
and all that it then gets restated as it
entangles with any aesthetic surface a
leaf a butterfly the front of your eye
but then it gets restated again as it
enters your eye and you know people have
said el greco had a certain kind of
stigmatism and that's why his people
were so long I don't know if that's true
but but that like does get restated in
the light harvester and then it gets
restated as a receptive reorganization
and creative so let's start with the Sun
the Sun is an initiator of almost all
sugars on the planet its initiator of
sweetness and life of prosperity it also
is an illuminator of the Commons and the
there's an aesthetic Commons in the
whole planet it's also a shaper of the
body so you get certain colors to be
hide other columns to be conspicuous get
a certain kind of eye and finally I'll
talk about how it's a governor of these
three
aesthetic Commons the Sun has always
been in human mythology until the
electric lightbulb honored for being
independent for being very powerful it
takes up one one hundredth thousandth of
the SkyDome and yet you can't look at it
for more than five minutes without
seriously damaging your eye it's
extremely powerful
it causes droughts it causes right now
it's causing greenhouse helping cause
greenhouse gases it also is very
constant for the last five hundred
million years the light reaching the
outer surface of the biosphere has not
changed by more than one percent the
only thing that has changed a little bit
and that's only up to ten percent is the
ultraviolet so it's been incredibly
constant some biologists would argue
that it's been constant for 1 billion
years in that 1 billion years that
constants T has allowed a common
aesthetic to evolve on the planet twice
in the history of the earth the anti Sun
darkness has been challenged the first
time it was challenged was by
bioluminescence you can see
bioluminescence in caves you can see it
in at nighttime and you can see it
especially in the deep oceans so those
two that rebellion is where life decided
that light was so important that it was
generated itself and it does it through
lucifer ice which is a kind of enzyme
named after lucifer that only life has
been able to evolve and it evolved it
not for life at first but you'll find in
both human aesthetics and in the
planetary aesthetics that one organism
will co-opt something from another
organism
to create beauty or forbidding looks in
this case these mushrooms co-opted a
antioxidant something to keep the
mushroom from essentially burning itself
up medic metabolically and it's probably
no one knows when that first happened
but around 250 million years ago a whole
group of organisms started to co-op
Luciferian many different forms in order
to glow and that glow is different from
the Sun it's a matte color it's weak its
it tends to only be associated with the
dark of the Moon and the rebellion
happened 40 times and 40 different major
phyla and it is no longer used as an
antioxidant but is used for display so
let me just go through on land of course
we have the Firefly and the glowworm
both of these have so evolved that they
now can mimic the signals the light
signals of other species and when a male
from another species comes it eats it so
we are beginning to see one of the
things that's true throughout the
history of the aesthetics of the planet
that danger and beauty always go
together and what we found is that right
now when art is shown in galleries or
museums or in churches it's in a safety
zone and so that tension that was so
much part of our evolution has been
essentially lost and we don't understand
that tension of beauty that comes with
danger and we'll see that all through
this talk it's a major theme at the same
time the oceans are 90% of the biosphere
the end by volume so in the deep waters
we have things like so
we have things like the squid here but
the squid did not evolve an enzyme what
it did is it ate a glowing bacteria and
it created inside itself a little world
where the glowing bacteria could live
well so that it could then used that
glowing bacteria as a lure for its own
feeding so what we're seeing here then
is that that mushroom by the way its
light can be seen by another mushroom on
a flat surface five miles away and fico
my seat nice my sees has actually been
shown to grow towards the other mushroom
at a distance of five miles
so here we are in the deep ocean with
all the different bioluminescent but it
wanted you to look at I don't need to
use them is that white space off the
Horn of Africa that white space is all
bioluminescent organisms when they first
were found mostly by sailors from Yemen
they claimed that it was the sperm of
whales then they began it began to
appear in Europe on rotted fish and they
claimed that the devil was attacking
Christ when hens laid an egg that rotted
and bioluminescent bacteria grew in it
they put the hen on trial in medieval
periods and they had to decide if this
hand had actually gotten in touch with
the devil and then at one point which is
really strange the story flipped and
became the story of the goose that laid
the golden egg so what was terrifying
became terrific we also saw it in that
not knowing what this was people like
Descartes thought it was because the
oceans shook and the friction caused the
bioluminescence but we can easily see
here
on the left is the underside of a shark
and the shark is creating that
bioluminescent throughout its body on
the right you could see in the upper one
the lantern fish you can just see the
lantern and the vague outlines there and
all this other we it would take too much
time for me to go through but
bioluminescence was this incredible
rebellion the second rebellion of course
was the rebellion of the human lamp and
the human fire and that started about a
million years ago when Homo erectus
started to control fire so for a million
years we were look human said and
staring at fire look on the right and
you'll see that that's that spectrum is
the same spectrum that the Sun is most
active as visible light so because they
were both incandescent bodies fire and
the Sun were very closely related and
you had emerging out of the center of
Africa in the upper nile you had the
whole idea and this always happens
whenever there's something beautiful or
some beautiful thought it's colonized
and it's colonized usually by politics
and power
well the origin of the Sun King period
of human history started in the place
where there is the most Sun right about
the equator and moved up the Nile became
part of the chip ssin Mesopotamian etc
Canaanite Sun King they were sun queens
by the way and they got their even
mosaics of sun queens but they got
rapidly suppressed instead what human
beings did is they switch from firewood
grass torches to oils gas incandescent
light fluorescent light LEDs sodium
vapor mercury vapor and this just shows
you how they are not the same as
sunlight and so we began to have a
change
in the source of light and what we were
seeing through the source of light and
that was a major change starting in the
1880s where the light really got to be
different when I was in Bolinas and
politics a huge debate occurred about
mercury vapor lights they were too blue
sodium vapor was too orange and which
one should we have in town and all that
kind of stuff what I want to say here is
that there was a period of time when
fire was predominant and materials this
is for Malcolm and when people were
making their objects out of for display
out of local materials and then all of a
sudden the light source changes the
color when you get electricity and the
objects began to change because they
would look different there's a wonderful
story about Rothko and Philip Guston
going into roughness galleries and he
would walk in the first thing he would
do is walk over to and turn off half the
lights because they were fluorescent
lights and they made his paintings look
too blue and they would stand there and
there and the owner would stand at one
corner and soon as Philip in Rothko left
he turned them back on but that was the
sensitivity to your light light source
and the changes of color of the surface
this was really important because as you
have ponds near street lamps as you have
new lights going up all over the world
and you can you've all seen those
satellite pictures things begin to
happen
these are salamander eggs and inside the
salamander eggs are chlorophyll and the
chlorophyll produces the oxygen that
allows the young salamanders to grow and
the salamanders actually transmitted
with a particular genome that goes with
it
but now under light
all of a sudden the chlorophyll is
working at night as well as during the
day and the salamander eggs are not
hatching so I wanted to say what
reflective light does
here's bird eggs right there is the
creative act in a bird in a him what
happened since the egg comes down and
then at a certain point the uterus does
a fresco it takes out calcium carbonate
starts to make it in the last two to
three hours it colors the top surface so
when the egg comes out you have all
these different patterns usually totally
unique but the light that's coming off
it is from a surface that's reflective
here's a human fresco and underneath you
can see the layers of calcium carbonate
and the blue pigments that form all
aesthetics well in the 60s the whole
thing changed James Turrell
Robert Irwin in LA all started saying
well why should we use reflective
surfaces let's use emitting light lamps
for creating aesthetics and this has
been I would say the unknown amazing
change because now that we switched to
an aesthetics based on new sources of
light we have a new parallel to
bioluminescence which was done 250
million years ago but what we see is
that everything now will be turning into
screens there won't be reflective
surfaces will only be emitted surfaces
and as we see that we don't really know
what as I said receiving as as important
as creating and if you're receiving
light from screens and not from
reflective surfaces how is that going to
change what human beings think about
creation and there's already evidence
that it's actually
causing different developments of parts
of the praying because people are only
looking at emitted light they're not
looking at reflective light I have no
idea what that's gonna be but I want it
to stay in this little section by saying
that as the world urbanize --is and
electricity we are changing the way the
world governs and not only are we losing
lots of insects to lights on the street
but on that lower left here you can see
a Daphnia and that Daphnia is in almost
all ponds lakes and parks everything
like that and it is attracted to light
and it usually only acts during the day
when there is photosynthesis going on
and now they're coming up at night and
using up all the energy to swim around
at night where if it's sodium vapor
light there is really no photosynthesis
going on or mercury vapor and so we're
changing the ecology of in ways we have
no idea what's going on in the middle is
the lesser water beetle it's one of my
favorite Beatles it actually has a deep
desire to land on red cars it loves that
the polarized red light and when it does
it lays its eggs on the red cars and the
eggs are very acidic and especially for
lowriders are just really a pain because
that where the eggs are laid it eats
into the five layers of the rider paint
on the right is a hawk moth hawk moth
has just recently been shown it can
actually tell colors in starlight it is
one of the few creatures that can
actually distinguish colors in starlight
and of course now it has no ability to
have that special niche because that
niche is being taken over by urban
lights
so besides being a source of life well
we see in the evolution of the earth is
a refinement of tonal contrast and tonal
contrast is best understood in terms of
like the Eclipse is the biggest shadow
we ever get on earth and but it starts
out with shadows and what well let me go
back if I can because it's good
the Sun has these particular
characteristics it has night and day it
has it but there's only a single Sun
there are other planets were finding
with two suns it travels across the sky
dome
despite Copernicus it life doesn't care
that the Sun is the center of the
universe whether I mean the center of
the solar system it's like the Beatles
song goes the fool on the hill sees the
Sun going down but the light his head
sees the world spinning round and
although the world is spinning round the
fool sees the light the Sun traveling
through the sky and I would say almost
all creatures do that so there's that
pragmatic and poetic again and I'm
afraid the poetic is controlling life
much more than Copernicus also you have
to understand that there's a top-down
irradiance
that you know we were lucky we have the
Sun is on top of us casting it down and
works with gravity so that we understand
up and down by the shadow that's cast
and also that the Sun is that optical
Infinity so by the time the sun rays get
here they're in straight lines this of
course was the obsession of the
renaissance which love perspective loves
straight lines love doing all their
paintings that way but few people
realize that bowerbirds in Australia and
New Guinea understood that a long time
ago and what they did in order to
attract a mate is they piled up big
bones and bigger pieces of Greystone
further away and so it narrowed really
fast and created a perspective that drew
the female in Alberta and into the
boudoir
they call him other things but it's a
boudoir
so back in 1880s the that's on your left
um this particular Japanese print came
wrapping paper to Van Gogh and it was at
this moment that van Gogh understood
that you didn't have to paint shadows
shadows in fact were only in European
art for 500 years no Asian art has cast
shadows the first cast shadow painting I
could find the one on the right was done
in 1856
after seeing Western art so the whole
idea that of the cast shadow was is a
really a peculiar thing in art but there
was a dialogue again between the poetic
and the Pro matte pragmatics if you look
at a slanted Sun you get this kind of
shadow and that cast shadow is ominous
it could be a predator it could be it
could be something that is dangerous
again the danger in beauty and so what
we find is that various creatures like
this Australian lizard created flaps to
hide the shadow
well artists did the opposite they
wanted to make a make the object more
three-dimensional so they added the
shadow and again that lasted I think de
Chirico was the last one to try he made
very symbolic shadows and then they kind
of disappear
from the art scene here again you can
see the caterpillar top lit by the Sun
is very obvious because it creates the
tonal contrast with the belly on the
bottom by putting a shade over it you
can see that it fades out more and in
fact a lot of caterpillars have darker
tops so that they can equal out the
light and again the artists were doing
the opposite but notice the two kinds of
shadow the cat shadow and the mottled
shadow of the body both of those have
been absolutely identical with opposite
responses so someone like - yep below
not liking cast shadows at all it's a
tiny one under the foot actually just
drew from modeled shadows and if you
look at the fish the top fish is top lit
like the caterpillar this one the second
middle fish has a dark back like most
trout have and if you can see it on the
bottom when you put that in the Sun it
evens out and the fish disappears so we
have that 2d 3d I can go you know it's a
long story but we have that 2d 3d
dialogue always going on between the
prac pragmatic and the poetic in the
history of humans and the history of the
earth the other thing about the Sun is
that it is not sunlight that actually
hits the earth it's a thing I call
biospheric light and you're not gonna
hear because I don't know anyone else
gave it a name but what happens is two
different kinds of changing light on the
left you see an early dawn and on the
right you see three different kinds of
atmospheres creating three different
colors of landscape the blue of course
being caused by fog and rain the bottom
is from a savanna in Africa because of
the way the Sun sets it creates almost a
red light goes through the savanna and
then
in the middle is the green blue green
light of tropical rainforest so and we
saw our authors of polina's so what we
have here then is a history of
background and foreground and what makes
something attractive what makes it bland
what makes it something to avoid
forbidding and what we understand in the
history of beauty and this is going to
be really contrary to academics is that
the understanding of beauty must start
locally in these kind of local luminance
locales you can't start with a grand
view of beauty because beauty is within
these changing contexts and so anyone
wants to get into what how creativity
takes place has to go into the
particular locale and see what bird have
what colors in the rain forest in the
savanna and how that relates to this
kind of light that's being shown the
local light well here here it is
mechanically these are all the tomatoes
of the same color but if you put
different bulbs on them again you get
different light colors again you can
look at the four boxes the box on the
upper right is actually daylight all the
others are bulbs like the yellow one is
sodium vapor that changed the light as
you're going on and so we're seeing that
light is that there's an impermanence in
beauty that beauty isn't this Universal
one thing that only happens in the human
mind I just want to quickly go through
this these are the ones in the ocean one
of the great stories here that started
maybe 3.2 billion years ago
was that one celled critters had
received light day and night day and
night the day length was only seven
hours it was in 12 hours the earth is
still spinning really fast and so what
happened is cells began to entrain that
light in themselves and the lowers
became part of their genome and part of
their mechanism of knowing when what
time of day it was when what moon it was
but that circadian rhythm came in
contract con I would say in contest with
the shading of the ocean which had so
many phytoplankton that now it was
darker in the ocean than it had been
before not only that but now predators
were beginning to happen around two
billion years ago it's a really long
periods of time and the number of living
creatures on the planet was beginning to
die and as the rivers came down they
were bringing organic matter
giving the ocean and yellower color
rather than that light blue color of the
tropical seas all of this meant is that
the changes that were going on were the
origins of one source of discriminant
discrimination and discriminatory
awareness all of a sudden the creatures
that could discriminate between what was
circadian and what was caused by organic
matter what was caused by phytoplankton
shading all of a sudden had a great
advantage because they could adjust
their levels in the ocean and again
danger and beauty they could then have a
longer time of survival by light being
the driving force for discriminating
awareness unmanned these general lights
also began to shape and this is the part
of the Sun that is a shaper
as well as an initiator and animals were
shaped by the kind of Sun and by the
local luminance locale that they were in
so these are kind of obvious white sands
produce white creatures grass produces
mixed and the dark lava rock produces
that what is interesting of what's going
on right now is that scientists are
becoming odd art artists they're
decorating birds with red splotches
they're putting a friend of mine many
years ago put those little bands four on
white-crowned sparrow at Point Reyes and
when it did the whole mating system
changed some of the white ground
sparrows were cool they had red yellow
and green and others were not so cool
because they had blue white and black
you know and so all of a sudden we
thought we were just identifying the
birds so we could be better better
scientists instead we were changing the
whole aesthetic world of the
white-crowned sparrow so here is a
really wonderful scientist named John
and Laura who took zebrafish and decided
just to take them into safety to take
them away from the danger of being in
the outdoors and in doing so he suddenly
wound up with a myriad kind of patterns
because there was no art critic hanging
around with a big jaw to say you don't
look go and so all of a sudden we have I
just wanted to give you an idea of what
happens when you let loose in a safe
region with no local luminance locale
you can you understand there's a lot
more variety going on in there a lot
more potential for creativity than you
would otherwise have noticed
um we're going back here again through
the Sun I'm always going to return back
to it and the yellow is the sunlight at
the top of the atmosphere and the red is
the sunlight that actually reaches the
earth
what this shows for those who aren't
into it of it is the size of the
wavelength of the caller
you consider yourself back in Bolinas
sitting on the bar
sandbar at the head of the lagoon and
some days the wavelengths are real slow
and real long probably came from New
Zealand and you can't get on to a board
and do anything other day and that would
be red light other days the waves that
come in are very rapid in fact too rapid
to find a crest that you could ride
without another crest bumping into it
and that's blue violet and ultraviolet
light and in the middle you get a good
ride so so what we see here in the
visible is that these are the
wavelengths that most penetrate through
the atmosphere and also are the
wavelengths that humans use mostly and
many other creatures but notice that on
the outside is the ultraviolet on them
and it's very energetic or energetic and
blue and on the other side is the
infrared and so what life likes to do is
take this free energy from the Sun and
absorb it into its body and use it in
some way with no bodily harm and so the
self over these 3.8 billion years have
been forming to do exactly that and so
pigments pigments of a mediator or the
interface between the outer world and
the inner world of the self and the
light comes in well it hits the pigments
it entangles with the in pigments some
light is cast out because it's too
energetic and would blow the circuits
other light is too weak and can
in there so what we're finding and this
is the hardest part is to stretch from
the visible and understand that other
creatures see clandestine colors the
clandestine colors that's a human eye on
the top and what a human would see the
bottom is playing those B's that much
more beautifully shown in micro cosmos
but what it didn't show because it only
used visible light is that bees cannot
see into the red they can't see into the
red because I have crystal eyes our eyes
are little pockets of the ocean have the
same refractive index we've taken the
ocean and encapsulated it so bees having
developed a whole other way of seeing
kind of more like pixelated crystals
cannot the energy of the red wavelengths
just can't get through instead though
noticed below the 400 that it can get
the ultraviolet and humans cannot do the
ultraviolet because our ocean is so
small that we can't mitigate or lessen
the power of the ultraviolet light
before it hits our retina and we blow it
out so we have this shifting it's not an
odd color it's just part of the normal
world met most birds many reptiles a few
Crustacea a few fish and many insects
see and have ultraviolet as just one of
their colors in doing that if you take
the red out and you shift into the
ultraviolet of course we don't really
know what that looks like
you know what ultraviolet but notice how
the flowers were change in tonal
contrast here's pictures in the
ultraviolet to show you just the
difference in colors the bottom one is a
carnivorous plant and it actually you
look at the white section of it which is
well the green section is how it looks
to us
and notice the little red marks on the
edge of the tips is to attract the fly
or the insect who has not seen it as red
but if you look at the next one
seeing it in the ultra seeing it in the
ultraviolet with a different color at
the end of these little tubes so this is
just to show you a few the other in
clandestine color of course is at the
other end of the spectrum I'll go back
which is the infrared and that set
really long wavelength and there instead
of like the UV where the energy is so
strong it'll break amino acids apart and
destroy DNA at a certain point except if
you're protecting it infrared is what we
call heat and it shakes up the molecule
and makes it rotate into all other kinds
of things so it doesn't really destroy
the light going in but then the light
can't turn from photons into
electrochemical so here just to give you
an example certain flowers despite all
you've learned in college actually are
warm-blooded and they can raise their
temperature and so they are very
attractive to bumblebees especially your
cat the reason has white in its ears is
to reflect all wavelengths and the
reason of course the way into the body
is through the eyes and that's the
window that light passes into so that
light also has a lot of blood vessels
and as big heated the nose as everybody
knows what your cat is cold I wanted
just do a few in here notice the
dragonflies standing on their head this
is to minimize the amount of heat that
they're picking up and the coloration of
bodies is a combination of responding to
heat and the need to communicate with
color so what we see here is that a
dragonfly
we'll have colors right near its armpits
or wing pits and it'll it'll just hover
like this or sit like that
the heat from the earth or the rocks
will come up and it'll catch and it's
formed a mini greenhouse and that works
best if it's a dark wing near the body
so certain especially northern
dragonflies will hold their wings out
like that and the heat will come up and
the reason for the color is not for
communication or advertising or hiding
it's simply there to be to hold the heat
and let the body heat up similarly with
penguins we find all the Penguins get
together and put their black backs to
the Sun which absorbs heat and their
white butt bellies they try to hide
because that would reflect they this
wood and shaped another whole group of
animals that in order to get the
infrared how how do they connect
infrared into an imaging system so we
see the rattlesnake has another hole
under its nose that absorbs the heat and
the heat then gets connected to the
visual system and the the rattlesnake
can protect itself from ambush did find
cooler areas in the hot Sun and of
course it can use it for defense or it
can use it for hunting prey we see the
same thing in the night the blind snake
at the bottom which is an underground
snake and the top of the beetle that
actually transfers his heat from the
back part of its body and can detect
forest fires at 50 to 60 miles it then
changes that heat into some kind of
visual image and flies and lays its eggs
in the still glowing embers on the sides
so the last of the clandestine colors
are really false colors there are the
colors of polarization and these are the
ones we know least about you can see in
DNF by using polarized glasses you can
actually see the shrimp and the fish
which you could not see and what we're
finding is that on the top is a
butterfly using polarized again a
polarized filter so but this is a very
interesting part because what we're
finding is that what we're finding is
that the way you see polarized light is
the way you do it with glasses you get
what it's called a match filter it's a
filter that will only see light in one
direction so if lights coming in this
direction and you're polarized light
your eye is this direction you won't see
it but if you went back in that
direction the light comes in and you
know you know directions on the right
although it's not so right on the left
although it's not a good picture is an
octopus looked at in polarized and non
polarized light and in the upper right
you can see is how the sky itself is
polarized and that's how many locusts
and other insects migrate so what what
is happening here is that you're getting
a matched filter which is very very
similar to what it's called iconography
among art credits you see across you
know what it is you know you see and
what we're seeing is the very early
evolution of one aspect of aesthetics
which is that you create icons in the
eye itself so a vertical or horizontal
in human beings the polarized light here
and that iconography creates a it's not
really a color but it's a special kind
of light so we they call it false colors
and what's interesting about that kind
of thing is it also creates a private
channel
it means that you no longer need to be
broadcasting to everybody I am here you
can make a aesthetic surface that can
only be seen in certain polarized or
iconographic filters this gives us now I
guess I have to go faster here but I may
have to skip a lot this just gives you
an idea of the how important the surface
is to light but it's all again like it
is in painting it has to be a compromise
between other things and painting of
course bacteria dust acid all of that be
used to eat at the painting and to make
yourself have a long life you have to of
course do protect yourself so my
favorite plant and this is the sacred lo
look Lotus sacred lotus has an
incredible self-cleaning device you can
see in the middle water does not seep
into it instead it just washes over it
and cleans all the leaves which
increases of course the amount of
sunlight it can absorb the flower itself
is the flower itself is one of those
flowers that can make heat and so its
pollination is based on the attraction
of insects coming to a hot flower well
what we see then is that you can make
surfaces by pigments by supports called
structural colors colors that have no
pigment whatsoever but diffractive in
the light to create them that's what the
back of cat ice is like and you know I
can't go into all this but other ways to
change the surface and get very
interesting in nature this is a Egyptian
vulture that looks for iron oxide
deposits and then uses it as cosmetic it
actually goes in and puts it all over
its body and turn just the way you
Goodbody this snail on the hand has
encourages a garden on the back of its
shell so that it now has created an
aesthetic surface to match the
background by actually gardening on its
own shell this of course is on there's a
no one is written but there's a really
interesting artistic military complex no
no I mean I said seriously you know like
the Army has really been concerned with
camouflage for instance like this man
and it's led to all kinds of cosmetics
it's lights all kinds of design fashions
led to Andy Warhol doing a kind of
whimsical camouflage series and but
again it's the application to the
surface just like vulture and face
paints and tattoos then you get art
that's separate from the body this is a
tight nest where the bird actually tries
to disguise that it has eggs by bringing
anything white that can break up the
pattern of having exit the genius of all
this of course of the bowerbirds that
make their own little art galleries and
then fill the art galleries either with
snails or blue clothes pins or whatever
their particular to become a good
bowerbird artist takes four to six years
a young male will sit in the bushes and
hide himself and watching other male
from four to six years in order to know
how to create this particular art scene
and then of course was the advent of
really capitalism that paint painters
started to make paintings that could be
movable they were no longer frescoes
there
large statues so we have also developed
a detached from the body art scene in
doing that the other principal shared
throughout the planet or that you can if
you break the contour line on a creature
it'll become bland
it'll just fade out and become part of
the background here's a copperhead doing
that and notice how the body is broken
up so there's no long contour line here
it is in black and white to emphasize
also notice that patches have a white
line next to them and that makes it look
like a 3d image that isn't the smooth
surface of the snake you'll find just
after you do this for a while you know
look you go into a museum and just look
at it and you say oh this guy's doing
the you know southeastern copperhead and
and if it's not working for you one of
the great things to do by the way is to
look through your legs you go to the
museum for your back sides of the
painting look for your legs and all
these other parts come out it's it's a
naturalist trick the other thing to do
besides breaking the contour is to take
random pieces of your background and
incorporate them into your art object
your artworks remember you know this is
art for life's sake that art for art's
sake so here is Verushka a model who
loved doing stuff like this
maniacal environmental something and
then in the lower corner you see the
same thing being done by plover eggs but
what has to be careful for years in that
upper right hand corner people said Oh Z
bruised were striped like that because
we blend with the environment and
and horizontal stripes like zebras -
Kilimanjaro picture it was easy for
predators to see and then some guy went
out and he took all these different
horses at different colors he put them
out in the field and what they found out
is that actually if you get a certain
width of stripe polarized light bouncing
off the body of the zebra gets confused
you can't tell where it's coming from
and that was really important because -
then it flies which spread a huge number
I was bitten by one in Senegal and you
just slap it and slap it and stop it and
it's still there
and it's just like rubber and pulls out
all this blood so horses or the horse
family in particular is very susceptible
to all the diseases transmitted by
abandoned flies
so that's why you see horses of a single
color especially all wearing protection
kids so instead of it being some kind of
communications camouflage and turned out
to be a different ecology finally what I
want to say here is that although poets
like to say beauty is truth and truth is
beauty actually it doesn't really work
in this case nature is great at forgery
to see making attractive fakes and poses
the question which really was a
development of the mind what is
authentic so we now see that the
evolution of the screaming
discrimination discriminatory awareness
the evolution of desire and the
evolution of what is authentic and how
to judge that is in a large part because
we are such a visual creature so you
just saw in that microcosmic this
particular flower that imitates the body
of the bee that was trying to mate with
it
but we also see
I'm sorry we also see up there the
caterpillars that joined together to
look like dead leaves the butterflies
that looks like another dead leaf for
ooshka again looking like a tree and
showing what mimicry can do by cosmetics
and look at this very carefully some of
you have seen this this is the Wow
picture for art and science that was a
letting go of some ink and now watch it
in Reverse
watch as the darkness spreads and the
body becomes more pimple so most
impossible to find the eye at the end
yeah so so that's probably the most
famous art video of the last 15 years
I'm serious eyed people I mean people
watch that I watch it dozens at times so
when I wanted to say if you look in here
as a head of Balzac you'll see two
priests make up his face and what Dali
was very good at was taking a double
meaning of two images you mostly you see
that face with a skull with two well so
notice what happens when you look at
color the color dominates and we're
looking vertically if it's all white we
look at shaped oval horizontally and
this tension again between shapes and
color and tonal contrast is also part of
the evolution of discriminatory
awareness that you see in almost all
creatures from single-celled organisms
up to us in fact white red and black or
almost black have are really the three
crucial colors and I'm calling black and
white colors on the planet and because
of that they have begun to govern the
ecosystems in certain areas note what
happens white reflects all colors so you
get too many colors you can't
discriminate them black absorbs almost
all colors but notice that doesn't solve
every color Matisse was in love with
black because he knew that he could
never make a pure black and he loves the
slight colorations of black and then red
is remembers that long wavelength it
won't harm the body right at the edge of
heat and is much more to make the red
you just have to be
how would you say it trying not to use
physics here um you just have to purify
the color by masking out all the other
colors and we'll see this is how it's
done so sorry there's a little science
here pigments this is a carotenoid a
carotene pigments in order not to blow
out always very long not only very long
but the carbons have double bonds that
you can see in the upper one and the
common a little more bonds there are and
the more structure there is to the
molecule in length the more it can take
the photons and the electronic energy
and move it up and down and around you
see at the very end it actually moves
around that comes back so what's
interesting about red is that's one of
the big the carotenoids make the Roy
colors red orange and yellow the black
color comes in part from melanin which
is one of the oldest pigments on the
planet and was originally there as a
protector from ultraviolet light in fact
Chernobyl to go into the belly of
Chernobyl there's a black fungus growing
on the walls and no one could believe it
because the amounts of radioactivity and
it turns out that this black fungus has
a melanin that can take the
radioactivity of Chernobyl and turn it
like we do with photos we like plants to
do with photosynthesis turn it into the
energy that makes ATP's so it can grow
so melanin no one's ever characterised
to melanin molecule when you try to
figure it out it falls apart so but
melon is one of the other main pigments
there are four main pigments on the
planet white comes in many colors
so here we have typical creatures of the
planet very different that are black
white and red and we can see right there
that the black and the red are highly
contrasted and the red is highly
contrasted because it's all of its
purity notice that all these three
plants are extremely dangerous
the the frog is a poisonous dart frog
the two mushrooms I think everybody
knows the Amanita by now again we see
the red white and black in this is a
prairie chicken and again it's about
danger to each other they're both
competing for females but we also see it
for identification care for the young
these are baby fledglings the mother
wants to know that it is in a cuckoo
that's laid an egg that might be in her
nest and one way she can do that is by
looking at the patterns of the mouth
which are red white black once again we
also see that it could be very helpful
for insects who are see some insects
Lucien's for the red certain butterflies
but we're seeing the carotene the
carotene colors the red orange and
yellow with nectar for we're both
hummingbirds and for butterflies and
finally we can see it also it's the
McDonald's caterpillar McDonald's has
red orange on a black sky trying to
attract you but notice that there's no
emotional value given to the
advertisement that has to be figured out
by the animal is this an advertisement
saying come here I desire you or is this
a danger saying red light yellow light
stop sign cold
so we can then see what happens then go
of course understood the ambiguity of
red and yellow really well and it was
just one of his paintings of course car
companies understand it so look at how
the red and the yellow stand out with
the white and the parking lot and but
also solar engineers now understand it
and they can understand they can get a
bit of transformation if they color
their solar plates red and you wind up
so two quick stories this is Nathan that
thirty forty million years ago a to
fungus and the fungus could produce
carotene oh by the way animals cannot
produce carotene there there's no this
is the exception carotene is only
produced by plants and certain algae and
cyanobacteria so when this ef'n ate the
fungi it co-opted the gene genome for
creating carotene how it did it no one
knows so all of a sudden what was the
advantage carotene is not only just a
color but as you health freaks know it's
an antioxidant and T tumor you know it
does all those kinds of things and so
all of a sudden it had one advantage but
it didn't no longer had the advantage of
the green - and right now in psychology
there are years of orange and their use
of chlorophyll Athens so this is another
way that color enters into the
governance here's a picture of look at
the bottom the red part is definitely
the carotenoids and that's ice algae and
the ice algae then is eaten by all the
phytoplankton notice it goes into the
ones that are chlorophyll related that
the carotene is surprised
you can't see the color but once you
have translucent animals like the shrimp
then you can easily see that there's
carrots in there that in term is eaten
by fish larger fish seals pulled a very
sufficient artic turn the point is is
that what's controlling this because
look at the lower molecule the lower
molecule is exactly half the carotene
that molecule is retinol it's the
crucial molecule for us to see it's the
thing that forms in our eye that allows
us to transfer light back and forth
turning off so what we're seeing here
although it looks like the polar bears
on the top of the chain actually the
polar bears at the bottom of the color
pigment chain and because he would not
be able to see to get his pigment out of
the seal on the fish unless he had
already been connected through the food
web - this red ice algae so I just
learned to to make it clear that you
know well what we have here is a
governance of life by a pigment we can
see this really now when there's a whole
bunch of invasive plants all over the
country that produce a red berry but it
doesn't have carotene it's a mimic in a
way and what's happening to the cedar
waxwings as you can see that in the
tails are becoming less red and so the
whole sexual life all sensual life and
the cedar actually is changing because
females preferred that little red line
at the bottom but males no longer can
produce it because they're eating
invasive species the other thing about I
only have two things what it all
the only things that we understand is
that because of the long history never
not only do we have polarized icons or
iconography but we have certain things
like the bullseye that have been around
in part because modern eyes are based on
us around but also because it's the best
way to get total maximum contrast out of
a line as you make through circles and
you have a lot of interface between the
light and the dark and so we're finding
throughout the animal kingdom and
perhaps in other places is that the
bull's eye is an icon and if you look at
this is a Robert t'lani painting and if
you watch your eye move around
you'll see it moves from one bull's eye
to another and this just shows you
different ways to make to maximize the
bull's eye we find it again in the eyes
of the peacock which uses that synthesis
around imitate the eye in its courtship
find it on the back of it this little
owl and that means that any predator
approaching it it's going to see these
huge eyes and think twice before it hits
it so what we find here is that we have
all what we are having is something that
lasts like eyes as icons and the 99
burfi of polarized light and certain
things that disappear and what we're
seeing is that image again images or
colors in a slice of time they're not
eternal beauty here is a Seurat painting
reduced I think that's going to be a new
form people are gonna have very thin
screens on their walls say well I'd like
to see what the painting looked
originally and then they'll press a
button and say oh this is you know 20
years later
what happened to the painting after
bacterial dust got it and this is what
it looks like now and which is the
painting that it's most beautiful become
and so we see that we're already have
having a new understanding of this
restoration make it more beautiful or as
the Japanese would say it's called
wabi-sabi this time make things more
beautiful and as the bowl gets older and
more shiny and a little chipped does
that make it less beautiful and this is
the second crisis it has to do with
first has to do with changing from
reflective surfaces to emitted light and
the second is trying to understand what
do we mean what do we want to call
beauty my mentor guy named Frederick
Jane Jameson big post modernist said to
me all art work is an installation you
just have to decide how long you want
the installation to last then van Gogh
wrote a beautiful letter when his
brother Theo pointed out that he was
using lakes to kind of die instead of
oil paints and that they weren't going
to last and indeed they've changed his
paintings tries to clay and he wrote
back and said my paintings are like
flowers they couldn't sail lasts as long
as they want there and when they're gone
there'll be other paintings and so he
had that same sense that this tension
about what is beautiful what is
deteriorating is not eternal beauty so I
don't have time right now but my
daughter asked me she said how do you
get from being attractive to being
beautiful and they're actually that's
where that desire comes in you started
asked adding hope is
an attribute of beauty contingency the
freedom the noticing of freedom like in
this poll is it's part of beauty so to
go from attractive to beautiful require
certain little steps that have yet to be
mapped out by biologists so what is this
is doing actually the screams and the
sense of what is beauty is maybe making
museums and to some extent galleries
less important because now if you can
have a thin high definition and it'll be
very high definition so you could have a
painting that looks as good as the Mona
Lisa original hanging on your wall
and you can push a button and see that
the sky was actually blue not that foggy
color so so what we're finding is that
this is a new area era of creativity and
creativity is really being challenged
people are now actually planning their
artwork to actually change so this is an
artist in the Caribbean who has this
gallery underwater made many statues by
taking face masks of people on the
island who are now turned into cement
and are becoming a coral reef and so you
can revisit the same gallery at a
different time and find that it's close
it has more and more fish has fewer and
fewer recognizable people and that is
the basis of you know of his art I would
like to end by just saying that this is
the oldest artwork by humans that we
know of maybe 70 75 thousand years and
the Aborigines in Australia has never
retouched it it was done by a very
shallow edging into the raw
and then a yellow fungus got into the
rock and started eating the rock and
then a red bacteria during the etching
and started working with the fungus the
yellow dots you see are actually fungal
bodies the red it's the bacteria and the
black is the fungal but is not the
fungal body but the actual actual fungus
they mixed up with each other cuts it's
kind of purplish tones and over 70
million at 70,000 years they've kept
their colors and changed it all the time
by so what weather is warmer the
bacteria thrive the weather got drier
the fungus thrive so this is probably
the best artworks for life and I know
and I just wanted to end by saying that
as a that underneath a lot of what we do
is the desire after the Navajo prayer to
walk in beauty and it's even if you're a
scientist you're trying you know trying
to fill some kind of weird mysterious
desire where you're tracking Beauty
curiosity where the self is where the
self ends where the non-self is the
outer world and what we find is that
since when throughout the planet when
there's a quiet time like at sunset and
you never quite sure what the light is
or that's why light near a coral reef or
in a museum or church that that quiet
time is a time where naturalist birds
I've sat with birds at sunsets
if you're underwater you'll see that all
life comes to a halt and there's
something about the transition between
daylight and nighttime and nighttime and
daylight and that's why that leads to
the understanding that at that moment
you can actually look at an object
without the fear of danger and without
the concerns of that something may be
poisonous gonna eat me and that moment
is a really old moment in the history of
the planet and I think it has the
contemplative beauty that many of us
cherish has nothing understood that
that's a guy in an aesthetic and I think
I'll stop there thank you that bringing
water you have more here
[Applause]
okay question from Alex can you talk
about the role of peripheral vision in
our experiencing of the world and by the
way to other creatures have her full
vision some some creatures can see 360
360 degrees
yeah that's peripheral yeah spiders have
eight eyes and depending on where they
live they just stack them up to wherever
they need to look so they can see many
of them can see 360 degrees and our edge
vision is a little more ghostly compared
to the kind of focused vision what about
well everything in the evolution went
from ambient light which didn't
necessarily have to be visual to
directed light which meant that you had
to focus in particular direction so the
eyes got smaller and then they suddenly
get so small that you can only see a
certain amount of light in front of you
and that means that we're getting less
light it takes a longer time to
integrate that light into the body and
so you now not only have less light but
you also have a longer integration time
and so at that point the most creatures
start looking around because they can't
see it
and so peripheral vision is one way to
maximize the amount of light that will
come in so that even if it's just a
little light it'll speed up the
integration time and that's that whole
thing that light is a sense or
sensuousness adds distance rather than
touch you know the blind men and the
elephant or hearing is such a big
wavelengths that it only in water can't
go very far and you know all the other
odor taste taste has to be done close up
so that's why vision became because it
can be done as a distance using creative
actual image of the world in your head
has become the dominant force in
sunlight for land animals since future
humans getting smaller ears and noses
and bigger and bigger eyes yes Catherine
S which creature has the greatest range
of color spectrum that can see like both
infrared and ultraviolet and anybody can
do that yeah a certain fish actually why
why do those fish do they do it because
they're getting they go up and down
mm-hmm so when they're up they want the
infrared which only goes in very short
and then when they're down
they want to use more of the blue in the
UV but I think that's I think it's and
they'll go from excuse my voice they'll
go from about 600 which is which is UVA
up to about a thousand where we have to
stop at 700 so but it's odd that it's a
fish right and feelin - crazy for owls
what dude nocturnal animals see
different ones different things so Hawk
moths can see color and Starlight
Jaguars can't see any colors at all at
night but they had very good because of
that - padam the thing we were talking
about the flashing of that cat eyes that
takes in this sort of light and they
concentrate it's it like a mirror into
the retina - so I can see more actually
the people who made micro cosmos are
about to come down to the Jaguar reserve
to make a movie just on that so I can
tell you a lot more next year but
certain animals like that blind blind
snake I showed you use the infrared as a
way of sensing and they feel the heat
in their little holes there but then
they transform that heat into an image
so at night a lot of creatures like that
that are right near the surface of the
soil are transforming heat into imagery
in ways where you don't really
understand to be honest and so that
would be an added color when other
colors would there be well the other
great colors are the bioluminescent fish
there's a fish that dangles a red light
maybe 3,000 feet below the surface and
it transforms a yellow light that it has
through filters into a red light when
the other fish sees it it comes up to
check out the red light and then either
gets eaten or they made but but the red
light is very short distance because
it's such a weak light mm-hmm saying
that so in order to but it can be seen
and in pitch darkness I mean that's the
deepest darkness two questions are laid
out go through both and muscat all are
asks will the gree are two color
temperature what do you think humans can
do to optimize their use of artificial
light throughout day and night for our
specific biology Kevin Kelly asked was
since 50% of humans now live in cities
has anyone studied the luminosity
profile of cities and yeah it's what
color's Modern Life so we're in lights
here are these the good ones bad ones
lissa TI good ones bad ones look at them
Oh Kevin I've been trying to pull
together all the information about urban
luminosity you get odd things like the
palm trees in Miami have never flowered
because there's light all night and they
don't they need a trigger some plants
need long day lengths there's a really
wonderful story
if you've read in the
Farmers Almanac it says only plow on the
dark of the moon and they're even
thought that was a superstition but it
turns out that if you plow on the light
of the moon
it only takes a very few small photon
flux to trigger nightshade and you'll
get nightshade all over the fields if
you plow on a moonlit night and then you
have to add pesticides and you get into
that whole ecology but if you plow on a
dark night and you have less than 1/2
you know enough photon flux then the
nightshade won't grow so what's
interesting the Midwest of course now
they plow at night using big spotlights
on gigantic and they wonder why they
have to keep on adding more and more
pesticides at the same time so even in
the ecology of farming now we see that
those kinds of things take place now I
could go in I mean obviously luminosity
kills 200,000 birds just on the east
coast who are migrating at night you
know every fall so luminosity is
definitely changing the ecology of
what's going on especially this
migratory birds
so some surprising advantage caking
going on I mean Ryan and I live on a
tugboat and right next to the dock
there's a light on the dock and then a
line that goes from our tugboat to the
dock and every night there's a
black-crowned Night Heron there fishing
right in the light from the light on the
dock and doing very well thank you
exactly I think probably fights with
other black grounds not particularly
ideal hunting site yeah so are you
seeing creatures are often pretty quick
to adapt to things since there's a lot
of City action going on and it's
increasing in its a relatively a
constant new environment to adapt you
what sort of things are we seeing in
terms of color and light that animals
are our plants are adjusting to the way
humans manage
I don't think we know yet okay I mean
West you know it's a good question and
all we know we know more about plants in
a way because different the sodium-vapor
is a mercury vapor the incandescent
because on soon to be LED lamps all have
their own effects on different species
but there's a really matter in the city
where there aren't that many species
anyway I mean I mean you know what
they'll do is change the horticultural
to adapt come on you've taken us on
field trips you know and we could barely
get out of the parking lot there's I
didn't have my flashlight no I mean
actually yes there's a lot going on
cities I don't mean to say that cities
are washed out but but you know all I'm
saying is that a different ecology will
emerge there for instance pyrrha campus
which is this orange berry that a lot of
people like to plant back east that's
the one that makes birds drunk exactly
and that's a whole new phenomena of
urban robins staggering around the front
lawn and so I mean we are and they'll
they enjoy it so and so we're seeing the
nature of desire change you could put a
little neon sign but now I understand
our firms weren't in North America until
the Europeans brought them so what did
did we not have Robins before I needed
you know red red Robins pulling up the
it was just one species of earthworm
right it was okay so there were other
things from DNR yeah but you know I'm
trying to think what was the question
before the one that Kevin asked about
urban Kevin Kelly saying 50 cents people
live in cities now that we studied the
luminosity profile of cities and he's
also sort of asking what color is
moderate
life right black-and-white start yeah
but but it depends on the street lamps I
mean really the street lamps are
determining so in Africa for instance
there's a kind of kite that just like
peregrine falcons are getting adapted to
the city the kind of kite that is all
over the city it loves it you know it
loves the rats loves the mice and so but
the color there is no generalization
about the color of the city Japan loves
a billion colors in their city they love
it to look like Las Vegas
well most cities where I live in Tucson
it's a law that you have to cover all
street lamps and only use sodium vapor
light in order to protect the astronomy
business on the mountains so again I
think it's a local luminance locale
issue that each local luminance will
decide you know what it's like some
streets to want street lamps others
don't so I don't think I don't think you
could make a generalization yeah do you
think well okay look you've been coming
from this long-term perspective yes in
slight since life both long-term stories
and this is long enough foundation
you've been telling a story that has a
certain arc so far I think and does that
suggest more of the story plays out in
coming centuries millennia well as I
said if we continue the way we're going
you know even Kindle and reading is now
emitted light the emitted light is
really gonna change the whole nature of
you know how humans exist because you
know I was a and some of you but we were
booked nuts when we read by reflective
light whenever the I wasn't we're it
intense I got a Kindle paperwhite now
I'm so pleased but I mean that's the
change
and that's going on and how come I liked
it so much in my life somehow
phototrophic in my you know you know I
don't know how much are we drawn to
emitted light we like sunlight so much
all these millennia and now we're being
able to make our own light it emits and
are we draw down it so we're stuck in
front of the computer screen well in the
colored lights we are because of the
purity of the light like neon really
yeah I mean the eye goes towards these
like in Las Vegas that's when they do it
you you know you see a certain pure
light or if you're McDonald's you put
the yellow next to the red it's the
black sky and you know pump out the
odors and but you know I think it's
really we're at a frontier I mean I
think this is really a new frontier
science following this frontier is it
sort of happening without a lot of
analysis no there's not
I mean for things that science is to me
is you know in 20 years plying people
will see you'll have little video
cameras that go through your eardrum
that connect into your visual system so
we're we're going to see so the blind
will begin to see the nature of local
luminance locales will be very
predominant so that you know like the
Bay Area's they'll be just an art scene
there and then that that art scene will
clash maybe with an LA art scene and
produce more stuff and that's how things
get globalized or world why this is and
we've seen you see that all the time in
nature or you'll have to locales with
different color materials techniques
traditions and suddenly they'll come
together and you'll get either a meshing
at the border or you'll get a whole
third thing coming out and that's why
you know I said that you can't
understand the nature of
attraction or blending or forbidding
except if you look at the local light in
nature I mean now that we're home maybe
cities will start didn't Tucson it's
already getting its version of local
light so last question your talk and
basically your life you've done a whole
lot of converging sometimes colliding
science and art scientists and artists
and they don't talk to each other
well some do but some do
so imagining that this wants to go
forward artists come around and ask you
if I was gonna get some science that
would help me do more interesting art
what science should I study outdoors
look okay no books no books that's
enough from the moment I get out I get
outdoors first outdoors look okay
scientist comes to you young scientist
is I like what you're doing and I would
like to be aware of artists I even do my
science what art should I know about
that's more difficult and you know my my
heart is where Malcolm Margolin is in
that you look at your local materials
your local techniques and you look at
the history of what could be created
from that because that's a tight ecology
and you start there and you you know in
a sense you look at Native art you're
talking about or yeah well yeah or
people who were in a sense trying to
understand local materials okay so like
in Bolinas what we did is we found a
vein of blue clay and so the first thing
you did is tell all the ceramic you know
try out this blue clay you don't see
what you think of it you know see what
can actually come from it's like the
watershed talk see what your local
aesthetics are and then you know
obviously even you know Navajo and the
Hopi they traded for abalone shells all
across the continent that's so you're
not trying to stop trade uh-huh
but I think for scientists tend to want
to read more books rather than go to an
art class and actually try that you
should learn to do art yep okay yeah
just you know not be embarrassed if it's
ugly you know just make it dangerous and
it'll be beautiful
yeah I mean I mean I remember being in
Africa and watching a cheetah run in
front of me and it was one of the most
beautiful things I've ever seen I mean
it was cheese stretching out and
suddenly it made this gigantic turn and
leaped on the back of a Thomson's
gazelle and just cut its throat
whoa this was beautiful is that
beautiful you know as is be as beautiful
as a you know and that's when how I
started my talk is that you have to
start out by saying all this beautiful
even the death of the thompson's gazelle
and then work back to see what it is in
your mind you're making a judgment on
you know what how did you decide that
wasn't beautiful in the art critics call
it abject beauty abject beauty yeah what
I mean
if you ever beat alsace-lorraine and all
those Christ's on the cross they have
huge thorns and their skulls and they're
bleeding all over the place and they're
in total agony why would any their in
Rome with a bunch of Apaches they kept
asking me what is that about why do
these people hang such a you know guy in
such a horrible condition of patchi's
are not known to be sissies for passing
they just couldn't believe that anyone
would make spend so much time making
such a painful representation and so but
yet most Western art critics could see
it consider those things absolutely
beautiful so so that's the Thompson's
gazelle right you have to go back and
kind and that's why it's a that's why I
love being a naturalist because I'm
always good you when you use a screen
and you're getting something a second
derived you're not gonna get those
moments where you're going oh my lord
mMmmm you know I think the octopus is as
close as you get to it I mean you can
watch that endlessly
it's my new Tonka
so but but I think that's the you know
educating is a very interesting concept
in a way and you see it a lot in war war
photography say oh what a beautiful
photograph you realize the guys been
just massacred by an ak-47 so what is
that line between ugly beauty and beauty
beauty and how do you do that and nature
is not going to give you any answers
alright so but so there's something you
do with your own their static I think
it's a personal meditation I'm sure I
mean I think that that's where I mean
people like Susan Sontag sounds like
you're saying if it disturbs you give it
some more attention exactly I mean you
do that in nature all the time mm-hmm
you know suddenly get eaten by ants a
little bit more attention it tough on
meditation when you're being eaten later
so one more time and I won't call it an
evening kidding ladies is you made a
point in there that you know the
question from your daughter
attractiveness versus beauty and there's
something else that beauty is setting in
motion and it was hope freedom what was
all that yeah at a certain point when
something's attractive you memorize that
you put it maybe into the bodily
unconscious whatever you want to call it
and there it sits and then in a way it
becomes the imprint for looking at other
things and becomes a transcendent image
and at that point you've moved from
attractiveness to a transcendent
attachment to some image for instance
van Gogh I'm using him tonight just
because they're too many artists
then go rights to his brother Theo and
says you know while I was painting this
I remember this itching from my
childhood you really see has no books no
computers no images and if you add up
all the images he refers to in his
letters it's a thousand two hundred so
he was holding a thousand two hundred a
hundred images in his brain that he
could rolodex at any time while he was
painting and that's what I mean by the
receptive so he'd invested in that
transcendence if this wasn't so he
wasn't looking it up online in line
right where he'd taken it in right and
then worked with it yeah I mean he was a
genius oh I mean he was bipolar among
other things so he had one of those
frames that if it started working he
could just memorize images and a
photographic thing but but anyway when
when you could go in from a retraction
to beauty one of the things that gets
added is this idea of transcendence
because you've now kind of experienced
another thing that gets added is an
understanding that to be beautiful it
has to have some kind of what's called
almost freedom of the moment in other
words you see a lot of computer art for
instance that's just too thought out too
many fractals you know way too many
Fraggles and instead you look at the
opposite let's say like Jackson Pollock
and all you see is someone who had
something in his mind when he was saying
him but the actual brush strokes or
stick strokes what everyone called we're
very free they were I mean unfortunately
he drank too much to get there but but
that is another part of what Beauty
holds so like Navajo medicine blankets
are never completed design but SWANA
baskets are never have a complete design
they always want to leave a little room
to escape the what the Western world lot
prefers which is perfection
so it's the opposite of what the Western
world at least in a certain period of
time wanted which was to gain a total
harmony balance gotten your kids out
there who go to art school I hope I'm
not undermining you but you know you
don't need to divide the canvas into
three unequal parts you know and all
that kind of stuff you know it's a
composition you know come you know the
best person about it is a one-page
document by the glad I mentioned you as
Tom dynasty he just lays it out it says
if you're gonna do it there's a
metaphysical part which is the Chi the
energy of the painting and he says I
can't tell you anything about that if
you got it or you don't know I mean and
then he goes on and then says he closed
them the bones the brushstrokes have to
be the bones of the painting and then he
goes through the right placing of
objects and then he ends up I mean there
are ten parts but he ends up was saying
that one must understand the convention
that I was talking about the iconography
and the tradition the phylogenetic
genetics that come out of it and then
from there work out of that but unless
you've gone through those other you know
unless you're I don't think a painter a
person can paint unless they learn to
draw first and so they have to draw and
draw and draw some of the classical
Kimura never stopped trying
you'd be sitting and you'd be drawing
something it didn't matter what you know
and oh we're making kind of erotic
origami you like to do that and but I
think there's that process for
scientists would be very revealing if
only because they would start and
looking at nature in another way I mean
if you draw I always draw not because I
want to be an artist but because by
drawing like I start seeing things I
wouldn't see otherwise drawing as a way
of seeing yeah and we got the basic
guidance here which is go out
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you